ken!
Pewdiepie!
Are you ready?
*laughter* they both want to die
That's not the intro, ahaha *they both want to fucking die*
yah yeet *logan paul who?*
you waited and I was like what? *R.I.P Ken*
Go ahead, try it again.
What is the most...
deadliest...
(earrape) ...I don't know how to intro this! [haha]
We're doing sad cringe!
Pewds: Sad cringe everybody! [haha]
Ken: No!
Pewds: What do you mean sad cringe‽   Ken: (laughing) Sad cringe...
It's a developed, acquired taste,
...to appreciate truly a sad cringe, Ken.
Is it like a... "You cry, you lose" kinda thing?
No no no, this is a "You cry, you win" Okay?
sad cringe sub reddit from... welp I mean look up
hey everyone I am in immediate need of
hell he said help but hell works too why not
so back at beginning of summer I bought
around 6000 fidgets spinners at a
wholesale to resell what a great
investment Wow only 6000 of them
let's see how many did it sell I just
only sold 73 of them wow that's cool he
only needs to sell 5927 more quick maths
does anyone want to buy some in bulk
what about you kid you want to buy some
in bulk I just can't wait what an
investment I'm getting desperate
I suck my life saving it to that oh you (sure why not)
know I look at Bitcoin and I'm like no
thank you
I will spend all my life savings in
fidget spinners who knows maybe in 20
years they'll come back yeah yeah like
pogs or something
yeah box hook came back that was a sad
cringe that was the sad cream Happy New
I ENJOY THE COMPANY OF UNDERWATER RATS  also just read it
may I kindly offer you to be my first
no reply no reply just humiliated on
reddit and said but dick moon I think(im not changing that)
about it hey baby me you know what not
poor Ethan he's gonna have to die I'm
sorry
then suppose it's on my page send your
snapchat name to me please
I adds you let's snapchat text me on it(great grammar bud)
text me on snapchat I'm already feeling
pretty thirsty ( lemme get you some water)an hour passes all right
not even an hour 20 minutes this is Josh
mom he just ran in front of a car(good)
oh no and I don't know he was gonna make
it he was a bleed from his mouth oh no
oh no not the bleed from his mouth he
could die at any second that's a mu
damage bleeding from your mouth and said
he loves everybody but I don't know if
he's going to make it and he loves you
do you care about him do you care about
him hi it's Josh now just got back from
the hospital * they die laughing* but like just listen
please snapchat can you send me snapchat
please well you know A plus for trying(R.I.P. JOSH)
he just ran in front of a car and get
the snapchat it's not worth living
divorcee selfie yeah the woman in the
back sling
that's a cringe window come on yeah it's
not a sad cringe he looks like he's
happy about it so I'm sure he's winning
hey exactly the dirtiest job be furry
artists make about $250 each Commission
and it takes me three days to do one
wait a minute
$250 why are we here three days to work
Jesus patron has given me over 4k a
month just to post my commissions
they're not even that well-known they
don't even know me and I'm making 4k NO ONE ASKED xD a month
plus $250 every three days vomit
about 5 to 6 times we're making these
Commission because I find freaking
disgusting *actually same though*this is exactly what it's
like to do you - Wow I'm just saying you
should go to prom with me in the trash
this is so sad  friend
zone so hard we look so much like a
couple here hahahahaha a couple of bestiessssssssss
did an escape room with all my femail (I can spell xD )
co-worker I was stuck in a small room
with three femailss for 58 minutes why
not just say an hour they smelled so
BAD LIKE FISH IT WAS GROSS and we touched HANDS so much I
literally feel LIKE IMA THROW UP oh my god it was NASTY
minutes of ecstasy I'm in heaven
every room becomes an escape room with him
I did an escape room for the first
time a few a week ago or something like
that and with no one touched hands okay
no one needed to touch any hand how's
this guy react like shake someone's
hand that's a femail (not letting that one go)
it's like when you hug a girl when
you're you're a kid and you're like I
feel something there this poor guy and
his ex-girlfriend my ex-girlfriend
bought this on my account I'm still hurt
from the break-up but Amazon is bugging
me about a review so here I am lurking
her Instagram to see the outfit and give an honest review on her behalf
even though I was unable to see in person she
looks great in this two-piece and it
fits every curve just right *kill me* could just
imagine all the attention she's getting
in this although I'm sad I'm very happy
she made this purchase man no its not poor
stop sympathizing KEN!  his ex-girlfriend
bought it on his account yeah well what
do you think she's got her money
connected to that account
heck no yeah but oh oh my okay so this is
what shows up if you search Google on
Bing why go there when you can search
here you can search right here try it
I couldn't understand a fucking word of that sorry
to be fair every time I've ever searched
anything on bing it's never giving me
what I want
really I have to go to like the second
page on bing to find what I want and
that's just asking too much ( no your just lazy KEN!) I never even tried it
(im sorry what the fuck did you just say?) this woman got
stuck in her bathtub for 30 minutes
after bathing in cocaine
there's no traction no grip just me and
my fat body slippin around covered in cocaine
must read like the quote they took just
me and my fat body sitting around
covered in cocaine as a news story did you
just tweet her or something she must had
like call the police I'm stuck in my
bathtub I can't get out this is what I
mean like sorry you lost it you life is
over now (R.I.P.) I would like to thank everyone
for a lovely birthday messages oh wait I
don't I didn't get any ha ha ha ha ha(R.I.P.)
let's say you know somebody's sad cringy
because they go I thought you just call
me out because I didn't send you
birthday wishes what a good cringy
moment there I I freaking put your name
in my calendar so I can congratulate you
on your birthday and I didn't even get
anything on my birthday and the only
reply I got from your birthday was like
oh you check Facebook no I did oh you
know who's never getting a happy
birthday ever
I know your birthday was coming up so I
Google a hey you what yep I am just got
home from work
nice how was that it was okay I guess
yeah so with why are you tired BITCH what
don't um me you BITCH I was big very polite
and you just ignore me your LOSS BITCH I had literally
got home I wanna know how long it took
for that BITCH to come back
why are you tired BITCH  like I needed to chill lol
you were texting before wow you have no
idea on what you're gonna miss out on
miss out 8"f pleasure down the
drain okay I think you have the wrong idea imma have to passs
don't try to play hard to get now
I'll see you it's over  whore ill see you in hell (it had never began)
okay my dude you had the wrong idea anyway
BITCH(not  translating what you can fucking read)
1k donation to her on last stream that's
crazy bro I'm still below top ten
donators haha okay squad bro I need 1k
donation please donate a little less
this month because four months of rent
we're overdue but I still got to do it
oh oh if I give a money they love me
yeah man I get it my wife's been bugging
me about this holiday but the squad
comes first look that's some next level  GOALS xD)
brainwashing right there this is
recently three days ago Jesus Christ
like how much it would be fellas save if
they just did two bits well you gotta be
tough it's for the squad for the squad
fam all right I think that's it thank
you Ken four sad cringing with me that
was beautiful I feel terrible I feel
good this is what I'm this gives me
strength this gives me power do you feed
off the sand cringe people's back in
consuming their souls you know check out
Ken's channel everybody in case of him
please drop some 1k donations they I
know he does live streams
stop asking about the broken podcast
please thank you bye I literally want to die is what he means *HOPE YOU HATED THE SUBTITTLES* :)